bonjour arnaud chiche merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur rtl france
comment est-ce que vous réagissez aux
propos que l'on vient d'entendre tenu
par emmanuel macron hier il n'exclut pas
je cite der confinement locaux ou plus
large
je cite également les mesures de
couvre-feu n'ont pas vocation à être
réduites mais renforcé toute façon la
situation est très difficile
on sait que le confinement ça marche
parce que lorsque ça a été fait au mois
de mars c'est bien il faut reconnaître
que ça a cassé la dynamique via les que
ça a permis aux soignants et aux
hôpitaux de gérer les cas hospitalisés
les cadres et animations voilà ce que je
peux je peux vous dire le confinement ça
fonctionne après le drame et l'eau alors
le couvre-feu en a moins de recul ça a
bien fonctionné en guyane
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le couvre-feu
dans les régions qu'ils soient encore un
peu calme
probablement que sa valeur est vite et
j'espère peut-être leur éviter de
basculer dans une situation dramatique
après dans les régions qui sont déjà
très subventions comme les hôtes france
ou de france où la région rhône alpes
je ne sais pas si on va pouvoir se
permettre d'attendre les faits du couvre
feu les hôpitaux sont déjà pris les
autres il ya déjà plus de places dans
les hôpitaux que ce soit en réanimation
ou alors de prendre les lits de mc au le
drame soulève le drame emmanuel maclou à
un recompte finement d'ailleurs le maire
les républicains de de nice christian
estrosi a regretté qu' il n'y avait pas
eu de confinement lui il aurait préféré
un confinement tout de suite selon ses
mots ouais mais vous savez monsieur ça
ce sont des décisions politiques moi je
ne suis qu'un médecin ce que je peux
vous dire c'est la réalité des hôpitaux
après je ne peux pas prendre parti
franchement pour une décision politique
mais vous me comprenez bien quand je
vous dis que le couvre-feu
je sais pas si ce sera suffisant dans
les régions de c'est très difficile à
l'étape d'après c'est le confinement
mais écoutez moi bien
le drame c'est que quand il fait une
conférence de presse comme ça à côté des
soignants il n'annonce rien pour
l'hôpital c'est comme jean castex ya
quelques jours castex macron vers ans il
n'annonce rien pour l'hôpital et
aujourd'hui les professionnels de santé
en ville dans les cliniques dans les
hôpitaux ils savent très bien qu'on doit
se mobiliser on se mobilise
déjà mais ils ont besoin d'entendre que
le gouvernement a pris la mesure de la
situation qu'il y aura une crise 3 nkis
4 en crise 5 et ce qui est scandaleux
c'est de se présenter devant les
français
et dire voilà alors il ya un dessin qui
représente très bien il ya une vague
d'une marée montante qui est énorme et
macro et distribue des parapluies aux
français et aux soignants et ça c'est un
scandale parce que moi là je suis sur le
terrain et je me dis mais qu'est ce
qu'ils font pour nous ils ne font rien
et il oblige des gens comme moi à sortir
de leur zone normale de professionnels
et je suis obligé d'aller sur les
plateaux télé pour sensibiliser
l'opinion des français et leur dire ce
gouvernement ne fait rien c'est à dire
qu'on est en train de constater que ça
va être un carnage
on est en train de dire oh là là comme
dit jean castex oh ça va être dur il va
y avoir des morts ah oui ça va être
terrible mais on s'en fout de ses états
d'âme on s'en foutent et d'états d'âme
vraiment lorsqu'on veut ce sont des
sujets que vous avez fondé a fait des
propositions récemment au gouvernement
lesquels oui oui et est ce que vous avez
eu un retour par rapport à cela
eh bien vous savez quoi j'ai eu un
retour hier soir tard d'une députée du
var la république un coup je remercie
papa les républicains pardon la
république en marche que je remercie
elle m'avait promis en début de semaine
qui a sensibilisé le ministre elle m'a
appelé hier soir pour me dire le
ministre fera zoom avec vous le museau
la santé la semaine prochaine et le
directeur général de la de la rs
d'autres france va aussi vous appelez
pas très bien sauf qu'en fait loi hier
soir j'avais monté une équipe
on était prêts avec mobiliser et à les
rendre service et en fait j'ai rien pu
faire puisque je n'avais pas cadres
administratifs et pas de cadre
législatif
donc non seulement ils sont en retard
tout le temps et mais en fait ils sont
trop lents et alors oui bah écoute et
j'attends j'attends le zoom avec
monsieur v rang avec impatience a
forcément parce que j'ai donc vos
positions qu'elles sont elles alors les
propositions elles sont simples il
manque de lits il ya deux items il
manque de lits et un manque de places en
réanimation
donc en fait moi j'ai imaginé un procédé
pour augmenter les vitres animations
c'est un procédé qui a été validé par
tous les experts la sfar des sociétés
savantes la société des anesthésistes
des réanimateurs des urgentistes les
experts et les aimer m ont validé le
processus c'est à dire que j'ai un
dispositif pour augmenter les lire adobe
réanimation en faisant fait
scission des forces un déploiement des
forces de réanimation voilà pour les
lits de réanimation et ses robustes
c'est un système qui peut être robuste
mais c'est pas à moi de l'organiser si
sa ket dingue pour les lits il manque de
lits à l'hôpital
on va pas les pondre les lie ils ont pas
été cap qu'ils en ont supprimé sans
milan en vingt ans on va pas les pour
moi toute façon ils ont intérêt à les
créer parce qu'il va falloir créer
cinquante mille mais là je dis qu'il
faut mettre les patients dans les hôtels
dans des hôtels on met les patients qui
doivent être hospitalisés pas trop grave
et on fait passer des ondes demande
l'aide des libéraux des médecins
généralistes et des et des infirmiers
libéraux parce que vous comprenez les
médecins généralistes
on leur parle pas eu ben on leur parle
pas donc les médecins généralistes ils
sont plein de bonne volonté mais en fait
ils savent pas quoi faire ils savent que
les hôpitaux sont encombrées et quand
ils ont des cas graves alors là moi je
propose une solution médecins
généralistes quand vous aurez quelqu'un
hospitalisés et pourra le mettre à
l'hôtel et ans et nous on organisera
toute une logistique pour leur donner à
manger et puis on pourra leur donner
comme ça les hôtels vont être payés et
en plus les restaurateurs vont devoir
faire à manger et 2 pourront nourrir ces
patients là et les soignants en étant
payé bien sûr et voilà voilà ce que je
propose il ya beaucoup d'hôtels en
france et donc alors la députée du var
elle m'a dit que dans le cadre de la loi
appelée la fss vous savez il voulait
développer le système d des hôtels ce qu
on appelle ça des résidences hôtelières
pour les hôpitaux pour éviter que les
gens dorment à l'hôpital la veille d'une
intervention
l'idée c'était de les mettre dans des os
chez le nom l'indiqué du vin vous avez
son nom au x j'ai honte c'est son prénom
c'est son règne du telus va je la
remercie je la remercie vraiment son
prénom c'est son règne je suis désolé
j'ai tellement d'appels que je n'arrive
pas à retenir tous les noms de famille
député du var elle est infirmière elle
s'appelle son règne et elle m'avait
promis qu'elle contacterait le ministère
elle l'a fait avec un résultat probant
puisque je vais avoir un retour de
d'olivier ferrand dont on écoutait je je
je je vois la fin je suis condamné à
attendre mais il faut que ces gens là se
dépêche parce que moi ma proposition
elle date des ados plus d'une semaine
sereine aux bornes donc depuis tellement
et voilà way
dernière question très rapidement on n'a
plus beaucoup de temps je voulais vous
faire réagir également arnaud chiche sur
l'actualité sur le million de cartes qui
a été franchie en donc un million de cas
positifs depuis le début de la pandémie
en et 67 millions d'habitants en france
environ ça veut dire qu on a au moins
1,5 pour cent de la population qui était
en contact avec ce virus
pourquoi il est si difficile de parler
d' immunité collective on en est où là
dessus monsieur monsieur c'est un virus
qu'on ne connaît pas bien d'accord c'est
un virus qui est vorace qui est perfide
qui ne s'attaque pas qu'aux personnes
âgées puisque je vous annonce que vous
le savez déjà qu'il ya quasiment un
tiers des effectifs de réanimation qui
concernent des patients jeunes parfois
sans comorbidités de moins de 40 ans ce
virus sur le connais pas bien ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'il fait des dégâts
donc parler d' immunité collective par
les deux vaccins ça je laisse la place
aux spécialistes que je ne suis pas
j'espère qu'on va trouver un vaccin et
j'espère qu'on trouvera un traitement
mais me suivre une chose qui est
fondamental à comprendre il faut que les
français comprennent ça c'est
fondamental parce que il faut que les
français comprennent ça parce que les
politiques ne l'ont pas compris
l'humanité est un peu attaquées voyez
quand on commence à parler d'un million
mort ça commence à ça commence à être un
peu sérieux
enfin un million de cas mes enfants dans
le monde je crois qu'on atteint les deux
millions de morts uj une bêtise
peut-être mais en tout cas on a dépassé
le million de morts je me suis un peu
exactement le chiffre en fait l'humanité
est un peu attaquées bon mais l'être
humain il est intelligent
l'être humain il a résisté à plein de
drame dans la dans son histoire
là c'est que c'est une épreuve donc en
fait il faut que notre classe politique
permette aux français de se défendre
mais là c'est le système c'est le
système de santé donc il faut investir
investira les styles merci le message
est passé arnaud chiche merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes anesthésistes réanimateurs
l'hôpital d'hénin beaumont et fondateur
du collectif santé en danger
merci